[Musik]
ich bin am freitag angekommen im hotel
und in der hotellobby waren die genauso
überrascht wie ich überrascht war dass
wir aufeinander getroffen sind und am
nächsten morgen stand dann vor der tür
eben eine größere abordnung von beamten
halbes dutzend beamte und die haben mich
dann eben darauf hingewiesen auf die
lage wie sie jetzt eben im hotel ist
dass es da ein sicherheitsproblem gibt
und haben wir dann angeraten auch des
bundeskriminalamts ich möge mich künftig
begleiten lassen
auf der münchner sicherheitskonferenz
ist natürlich wirklich ein affront wenn
ein deutscher politiker hier in
deutschland personenschutz braucht das
vorgehen um es dem ihr zeit geben
wie können die drähte zwischen türkei
und deutschland sind auch hier brauchen
wir wieder diplomatie verhandlungen und
auch klare forderungen deutscher satz
also ein deutscher abgeordneter dann
sondertagung teilnimmt er muss sich frei
bewegen können das ist ganz einfach und
wenn das nicht funktioniert das ist das
aufgabe einerseits der
sicherheitsbehörden hier und
andererseits aber der deutschen
regierung klarzumachen dass das nicht
akzeptabel ist
ich hoffe dass sich das schnell
widerlegt und wir da zu einer normalen
zwei normalen börding untereinander
kommen
also auch nach der freilassung von davis
l sieht man allein schon an diesem
symptomen das noch lange nicht alles gut
ist in den deutsch-türkischen
beziehungen sind immer noch über 40
deutsche in haft über 30 werden an der
ausreise gehindert
über 60.000 menschen sind noch wegen ich
kurz verdacht hin haben und über 150
journalisten
ich sage da ist die türkei kein
rechtsstaat wir dürfen aber nicht den
draht abbrechen lassen sondern müssen
das immer wieder anfangen